when his game yesterday bringing him to
a plus one score Alshon in Toronto
Cobian are both following with Brent
Jacobson now at an even score and
unfortunately for Christian he once
again lost his game yesterday why don't
we take a look at the format for this
tournament and see what the players are
up against all right all right
but that was the only way we were going
up is that what he said I'm confused
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as us chess champs calm
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
summer chess classic we're here today
with round seven we are your hosts my
name is Caleb Demi and I'm joined of
course by Grandmaster Jessie cry I think
we had some technical issues there but
we should be live and ready to go now so
once again welcome back to round seven
yesterday was a tumultuous day as we
were saying and the standings have
really been shaken up so why don't we
just take a look and see where the
players sit after around six in Group A
David Howell and Jeffrey Zhong are both
still tied for the lead with no real
changes happening up at the top
yesterday Sam Shanklin and Gawain Jones
are now following with an even score and
Liam Lee actually brings his score up to
a level three out of six after winning
his game yesterday against Darius Swedes
in over in group beat
Grigory Oprah is now the sole leader in
Group B because Surya Ganguly
unfortunately fell yesterday to a
tournament last place in Group E Igor :
go who seems to be heating up just
despite his slow start to the tournament
Sam sofyan managed to win his game
yesterday as well bringing him to a +1
score tied with Surya Ganguly a half
point out of the lead lavon's kuboos Ian
is still following with a level score at
three out of six and over Group C
archers night suns now leads by a full
point thanks to his win yesterday over L
Shaun Moratti abadi
it was a very crazy game and all Shaun
definitely had a lot of chances to take
down archers but our tears came out on
top after some some tricky end games
some tricky end game play Dmitry
Gordievsky managed to win his game
mister day as well bringing him to a +1
score the closest man in the field to
our turfs well although it'll be
interesting to see if he can close that
gap before the end of the tournament
also notably Brandon Jacobson seems to
have recovered from his unfortunate
middle of the tournament
started off leading and then lost a
couple games but he's back on Form
winning his game yesterday
greeing his score back to even and let's
take a quick look actually at the format
for this tournament there we see the
playing hall and there are three six
player double round robins so there are
three different groups as you saw in the
standings and everybody plays everybody
twice so as we're in the latter half of
the tournament these players have all
seen each other before now the time
control for this event is 90 minutes the
first 40 moves with 30 minutes tacked on
for the remainder of the game after move
for you there's a 30 second increment
starting on move one and there's also a
30 move draw rule in effect so no
drawers before move 30 except by
repetition and lastly let's look at our
schedule there's one game a day with
just that one rest day in the middle so
no more rest days till the end of the
tournament we'll be here every day
starting two and a half hours after the
start of the rounds through 1:00 p.m.
and our broadcast at 3:30 p.m.
although notably the grand chess tour is
starting up tomorrow in Croatia so if
that broadcast happens to wrong run long
we will still be here but we may start
just a few minutes late depending on how
those games go as always you can join us
on YouTube
you know we're watching that chat we've
got got an eye on it we see you guys in
there and you can join us on Twitter
using the hashtag summer chess classic
and you can follow the games yourself
live on us chess champs calm if you're
interested see what's going on well
Jesse I think it's about time to jump
into it for the day let's see what the
pairings are in group a Liam Lee is
paired against tournament leader Jeffrey
zhang darius roots is also paired
against tournament co-leader David
Howell and then our key matchup for the
day is actually between Sam Shanklin and
Gawain Jones these players drew in the
first meeting of this tournament but
they're both looking for an opportunity
to catch those leaders a win today will
likely do it for either of them we see
the players they're looking at the board
and why don't we check out what's going
on over the chessboard right it's been a
really great game and like last round
we're going was on the black side
a groom felled and then had to find his
own way that gets Jeffrey John Sam also
played basically the same variation and
going again had to figure it out on his
own and his again playing great and I
think he's definitely got the edge here
let's go back and take a look how it
went so we had our groom felled business
here and like with Jeffrey Shanklin
chooses Bishop III rook c1 and we're
just playing a system where we're trying
to consolidate our Center and in that
that game with Jeffrey Guin castled and
here I was in there you know head
watching it and going clearly started
thinking here and is wondering like what
should I do this guy has prepped against
me but like I said before one of the
beautiful things about knowing an
opening is especially one like this
which is I guess I would call it half
open with a lot of strategic ideas
there's always gonna be some idea that
you can throw at your opponent and it
gets real spicy right away with Queen a5
Queen d2 Knight f3 Bishop g4 d5 and now
this amazing move b5 so up until this
point
Sam had played you know just making his
moves instantly and now he has to make a
decision whether he wants to take the
pawn on c5 or just develop and taking
the pawn on c5 is very risky because
black gets some development and if you
take this one I mean you can think about
it there might even be a different move
but in any case this is gonna be a huge
counter-attack now does white maybe
still have enough because he has two
pawns maybe that's I'm certain one of
the things that Sam was asking but it's
incredibly dangerous to do this this
looks pretty crazy
so instead Bishop e2
97 and let's just say briefly the idea
in the green felt is you've got these
pawns and you you want to use them for
two reasons one to create enough drama
on the side of the board that white
central majority doesn't squish you or
come at your king and two to make some
kind of play at the center and in this
game it's gonna be hard to see how we
come at the center but watch well how
this happens so Bishop e2 ninety-seven
castles rook d8 I'm sure there were
other moves but this all made a lot of
sense rook e1 and now watch what going
does he snips a right away and it's kind
of a funny decision because you're
giving white the two bishops mm-hmm and
you're saying oh that's okay I am gonna
have this blockade square and I'm gonna
claim that in this guy on f3 is not so
great
my understanding the green fold is it's
all about the the dark squared bishop
and so I thought this was a pretty
common idea to give up a light square
Bishop for the night so that your dark
squared Bishop could be a little bit
more powerful on those dark squares yeah
well okay check it out c6 or a c4 they
should be there are h4 this is our this
it's even hard for me to you know I'm
getting the vice a the moves wrong not
looking at the screen because it's so
complicated so c4 has a couple ideas one
is to land the knight on d3 not
seemingly also not worried about Bishop
d4 and here I don't know I feel like Sam
lost his mind
okay let's say a human move would be
something like Bishop d4 or maybe even
an interesting try like a four it looks
kind of weird but the idea would be if
the Queen takes you run the room in any
case this move
it's not it's speculative in that it's
not clear that the H pawn is actually
going to deliver mate anytime soon and
it might turn into a weakness and so
what's interesting to me about the next
couple moves is his Gawain sees this as
his hey how should I say his another
only opportunity but like his validation
for going for the crazy so here we go
d6 Bishop g5 in a very simple plan 95
and that's what I mean by going by the
validation that's the wrong word but any
case if you take now your king side is
wrecked and the H pawn is under fire
justification may be justification in
any case yeah so giving up possibly the
rook in exchange for those little
shattered pawns well in sanguine says I
don't want it understandably and then he
says I think he might have won it
because this is even more crazy and I
don't I know fans remember last game but
there was just an incredible struggle
with Gawain is black and he also played
a position that is very reminiscent of
what happens now with pieces hanging
everywhere that resolves into a
positional struggle so h6 Fe snip-snip
and at first sight it's hard to tell
what's going on but the bummer is that
it's very difficult basically impossible
for white to hold the e5 pawn because
white black is not going to open up the
rook and when that pawn goes the dark
squares are going to go
so it's interesting moment here so
there's I think there's more than one
move black could do black says I'm gonna
try to beat you even without the Queen's
on and at first I felt like okay maybe
this is just gonna like head for a draw
but Oh whites made some weaknesses and
it's still a problem so snip snip this
is very accurate move of course most
players would want to play that without
thing
too much about it there's two problems
one is Bishop g4 and the other is when I
do this that we're gonna see in the game
I play rook b1 you can't defend because
I'm gonna play Bishop c4 so that
connection between the rooks you need
the rooks be connected so dd8 a4 rook b8
it's very intense and it's feels I think
a lot of players would think that this
would be a draw but actually I mean what
white might achieve a draw in this game
but there's actually some real suffering
to be had here because the dark squares
are going to be weak and you can see
that the c3 pawn fell kind of inevitably
to rook b5 and here was it the moment
where black really decides to go for it
with check King f1 and then no trade and
so now we have this interesting moment
where white has to really be sure not
only to not lose because of the C pawn
but the King could come under fire with
a move like f5 at some point as well
that was why Sam really thought for a
long time at Bishop d4 now one thing
maybe I don't get and and we're gonna
see that in the what's played out now is
that if black wanted to play rook b c8
like he does in the game then maybe we
should do it here because in the game
position now maybe black has something
planned but there's this question to be
answered and I'm assuming going at some
kind of idea here but I don't see it yet
so hey I'm sure Sam's thinking it was I
miss thinking about it right now games
watch and so I don't know if there's
some answer to that move it seems like
if there's not it's just gonna go in to
a draw but you can see like I wanna
wanna stress is those weaknesses on the
dark squares really mean that we can
keep playing here alright
I guess they're in it for the long haul
then so I guess we'll give them some
time to figure out what's going on
actually let's let's see a couple moves
have been played sure so where do we sit
rook b c8 d6 was played okay so they
understand something that I just don't
necessarily look happy to see if do you
see anything here am I missing something
I mean maybe f5 it doesn't feel like f5
should be it but maybe I'm worried about
anything it's f5 and notice that if I
get that then it's totally over right so
if I just take the pawn I guess they
take me for with the check i play king
e1
oh but watch this I can go check to the
misérable King and then take here so
maybe you should take on c4 with the
bishop right yeah that looks like a
better try oh but there's no squares
Keeney 1 this falls teeny to you I mean
you I mean that's yeah right okay so the
question was Hester as what did what the
deal was
and the problem with d6 is that that
pawn is lonely that pond is lonely it's
gonna be very hard for black to for
white to back that pawn up c3 is not
lonely they should be three and rook cd8
so Sam is in big trouble
notice that the idea I think of rook cd8
is now if every five works still gonna
play f6 the rook on f8 well it looks
dormant very much once out against the
white king this is this is gonna be
tough to hold I guess the question for
black is can you keep enough pawns on
the board to really make this work
well once you move like a 5 f6 and then
g6 becomes weak and I think we actually
see that happening on the board
right I think black I think it's I mean
I think it's lost honestly because it's
not just that you lost some pawns it's
that the King is gonna come under attack
right so this just happened yeah and
let's just assume Brooke f6 mmm-hmm so
yeah poor King is toast you two are you
on it not neither work and once and and
I always have a default of just taking
this guy whenever I want
mm-hmm so that looks real bad that looks
terrible that looks terrible
so Gawain Jones the master of the groom
fell do not just don't even mess with
this guy in the group so if Gawain wins
today of course then that that puts them
level with the leaders Jeffrey Zhang and
David Howell unless one of them manages
to win today as well right and so after
we look at our other groups we'll come
back and look at Jeffrey's game Jeffery
actually lost so we're gonna maybe we'll
talk about that soon yeah breaking news
so yeah Jeffrey one of the leaders did
lose this game against Liam Lee right so
that'll definitely shake up the
standings but let's take a look over at
the pairings in Group B Igor Kovalenko
is paired against Daniel Friedman which
I believe that game has actually ended
in igor's favor
so Igor went from the bottom of the
standings to two wins in a row very
impressive stuff from him the tournament
leader Gregorio proned is paired against
Sam seven and then
Surya Ganguly against Havana's Qaboos
ian is actually our key matchup of the
day Syria of course lost yesterday
bringing him a half point out of the
lead but with the win today he would go
back level with that plus two score so
we see the players there in a very
complicated position which I think might
favor the black pieces what do you think
Jesse well before we get into this I
want to tell that fruit I want to tell
my friend Igor Kovalenko upstairs buddy
come down who played a brilliant move I
don't know if it's a brilliant game boys
is definitely a brilliant move so we
want to talk to you about it down here
in this game with Ganguly I definitely
felt that Ganguly out plague abou Xion
early on and we've actually seen that
almost every game
of ganguly said he's out playing his
opponents and sometimes it has grief
later on but definitely playing some
beautiful positional chess right now we
have the dream of the whole blacks
opening with the everything coming alive
right right
some complications but that that pawn on
c4 the rook on b4 out all of the pieces
seem to make a lot of sense for black
lets back step just a touch so we had
this complicated position here and
actually maybe even here I was feel I
felt for sure white was better here
queen f1 Queen e2 we've got look at yeah
everything's coming together right
everything's coming together any so I
felt it's kind of slipped here so 85 I'm
not sure I understood that move this
would be six Bishop a4 again I'm not
sure I get it
Queen f1 and then taking that pawn
unless unless we get something radical
for it it seems like we're just
activating the silly Bishop on e7 hmm
right yeah z4 x glam and notice the
bishop on a4 has a little grief now f4
94 a simple chess f5 93 Bishop g5 so
ganguly yeah it's been a rough couple
rounds I don't know I'm sure he's
calculating Fe now to see if he's got
any something-something yeah this is my
guess optically it doesn't look right
but yeah well what do you do with black
do you take back on u6 do you try to
take d2 somehow I think this is a luxury
decision ie I think I can do more than
one thing okay
I'm gonna save the Kovalenko game mm-hmm
because that I think we're gonna talk
about that in the studio yeah and then
let's go to a group seat yeah let's take
a look at the pairings for Group C and
then see how the games are shaking out l
Shawn Marathi body is playing against
Christian shrila today tournament leader
archers Naik songs was paired against
our own poco bein in that game ended
peacefully I think our turfs is maybe
finished with these these crazy
back-and-forth games and wants to
solidify his lead and we'll see how that
works for him because Daniel Gordievsky
is right on his tail today he's paired
against boy genius Brandon Jacobsen as
we like to call him in a win today would
put him a half point behind tournament
leader archers Naik Suns we see the
players there at the board they drew in
their first meeting in this event but
there's a lot on the line now if Dimitri
wants to catch our tourists he really
needs a win today well right and it's
been a weird who a very unfortunate
thing for Brendon because he definitely
started off let's just say either well a
pawn up without that much compensation
for white here so here's the position
that it's called the first critical
position where black is up a pawn and
white is honestly not doing all that
much just fun doing that much so you
know you can make a variety of
strengthening moves here whether they're
one of the rook moves and h6 moves
you've got a lot of choices
Brandon decides let's do it right away
and it gets a little hairy
it goes a B Bishop d5 Queen B 1 C 495
and I'm gonna suggest that that's the
move that Brandon's somehow
underestimated because now there's just
simple problems with this diagonal and
maybe you know sometimes you get
overconfident because it feels like your
opponent's just down the bar and it's
time to break but c5 definitely in
hindsight seems premature with 95 the
best Brandon could find is bishop d8 but
now
we're we're just up upon yeah it's quite
the change right so black with the white
one is pawn back and one more and not
only that but like even if he wasn't up
upon we would still say white it's a
little bit better
he's got the rooks better the bishop you
know the bishop on d8 has to get fixed
so Brandon's having a rough time typical
game but this would be huge for Dmitry
if he wins today just a half point out
of the lead with two rounds to go is a
great position to be in
yeah it looks great and you know he
started slow we had him in the studio
yesterday and at least the way he spoke
he seemed to have a huge sense of
purpose going forward to at the very
least play fighting games and so of
course he started the tournament with I
believe five draws so he's right his
first win yesterday if he won another
one today I'm sure that would do a lot
for his confidence moving forward being
able to convert these types of positions
where he should be a lot better so where
do you want to jump to now let's look at
how Geoffrey lost this game alright we
had two Sicilians that went with this
Knight f3 variation today and I have to
say I'm so old that this Knight f3 stuff
still strikes me it's funny even though
it's been named in theory for a while
anyway so we get this thing and this is
very well known and Knight h4 was the
first move that I could tell where
Geoffrey was thinking about stuff I
don't think it's not that special or
anything g6 and then back and so we're
gonna try to play Knight g5 is the idea
95 anyway so we're not really
threatening the rook because of f7 and
black has a number of moves here I'm
sure Knight bt7
either now or one of the next couple
moves would have been fine Bishop f8
snip snip snip f4 and white definitely
now has some initiative ef4 now the
problem is that if rook f4 there's Queen
c5 check and the night falls
so the MV just placed king h1 and
actually this is interesting in the
sense that Geoffrey
it hasn't played the Sicilian that much
this tournament but in general that's
been his MO for his whole career and
what he has done a lot is play to my
mind to provocatively and this game is
an example of that where for example
here - he's not going to develop his
knife block to clean off Queen C 5 this
is a very very interesting move like why
why take the time to move the Queen
right now when uh he wants it all
and look at this move he wants he's
saying I can play without the night and
this is an interesting position because
maybe we can get the elite in here
because just optically it seems like
black is saying I want it all and then
it's like well that's a very intuitive
sacrifice right everything's undeveloped
and we start taking stuff and hello Here
I am
alright well you're taking a look at
this yeah I believe actually of Liam Lee
here so I'm gonna step out and let you
take over
and let's try to do two interviews
hopefully we can do them Lee and
Kovalenko all right let's see if we can
get that going all right while that's
getting arranged I want to show you guys
this position with Gawain Jones
we have ef6 and the natural move would
have been rough six oh my rook is got a
little drunk there let's get rid of the
head arrow rook f6 but instead black
played Bishop f6 which of course also
makes sense threatening the discovery on
the H bar and when rook d6 comes it'll
hit the bishop
so the main problem for white isn't to
fold the pawn on c3 plus the dark
squares right as we've said another
broadcast when you've got the opposite
color bishops black in this case will be
up a piece on the dark squares and white
will be up a piece on the light squares
yeah so beautiful game and we're gonna
follow that and poor Sam is suffering a
little bit and while we're getting then
leap in the gate let's just briefly look
at this fear towel game and house doing
great okay so I have Italy here with me
and how should I say your name what's
the best way to say it
Linley okay good I'm saying all right
and you played a great game today
and let's just have you walk us through
it here maybe we'll start let's say here
okay so you chose do you have any sense
why Geoffrey played the night off
against you but not anybody else
surprised he played g6 first move
against terrorists right early around so
I think his opening is a little bit
unpredictable and right I don't know how
he came up with this but it's my first
time playing it's just me three I don't
think he right okay this is all kind
this is all it feels normal to me yeah
right and then maybe that was the first
newish move but he was thinking about it
I remember looking yeah I think he was
just so g6 seems right mm-hmm there's a
page six yeah probably the first
critical moment of the game okay it has
three squares for the rook mm-hmm
I think pH is supposed to be the best
move because
you know just in case you want to defend
it Luke CH there may be some tricks like
windy 295 and maybe that's why he didn't
like it so he played to create to defend
the six and at the same time threatening
matches before right
but in the long run it might be just
misplaced on the end it might be in the
game he had some trouble defending it
six so after the p8 I play 93 and he
couldn't play 9b d7 I think because the
difference is now I can tell you in
today and tonight you find right so then
yeah then he just played Bishop I fight
and depending everything but here you
have to play Quincy floor and then then
Queen f3 and I think what what is better
because some finish 3v3 sometimes sure
yeah okay good that's an important
that's good to know
so Knight g5 now maybe I missed
something here but in this move in
several other moves I thought he should
play Knight bTW Center I thought so yeah
yeah
Bishop effort I think it's a mistake
because he be sharp his Bishop was
necessary to defend the Kings and and
trading that we can these positions but
I think he did like 9b d7 Queen f3
my fates finished three what is white
threatening ninety-five
what is white threatening of 95 years
okay right so I feel like I feel like he
could do all kinds of stuff maybe here
it's possible so yeah I mean I would
just buy something like rookie one and
no way to see what is okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah the main problem is that it's
nighttime if six cannot move and so I
felt now maybe I have a totally wrong
narrative of what happened here what I
felt like he was really pushing it like
Bishop f8 is this very strong claim of
like oh I'm gonna trade my bad bishop
for your good Bishop and I don't have to
develop my stuff right that's what it
feels like and then he makes some other
big bold moves later - right yeah I
think maybe t7 first and then Bishop f8
sure and sure it makes more sense yeah I
mean if we're now FR if my rook was for
example on e 1 then i couldn't have
disadvantage sure but yeah it seems to
me like he should still be thinking
about night BT's oh yeah yeah that's the
problem
well at least maybe he can check first
simply a minute one yeah he could do
that yeah so maybe this maybe that's
what he should do
your your you obviously have a nice
initiative you could play f5 you could
do other things yes but but right it
felt like that's like whoa developed
every develop nice move very nice move
yeah probably EF is the critical mistake
as you say quints if I first and every
discipline has to be playing after yes I
think English one is already so close to
winning right yes because I'm let's show
the audience when he plays quick so he
can't play Knight bt7 now because of
Queen d6 yeah
okay we were discussing miss Lanford
again and that's the dress that might be
determined just give up the pawn and try
to defend that and game but still you
know no bt7 group sorry Queen takes
three three three you can't take that
thing
[Music]
Oh
what sort of King g8 was more accurate
okay Kim G because kimchi is after nine
eight seven Queen f7 e five days not yet
I think okay yeah so the King has to be
on and she ate that yeah but this is
obviously yeah but it's already Pleasant
for me I can just go back now sure sure
okay so Queen C 5 and now you cut the
Queen from the defense very nice
yeah Haley here was probably the last
mistake he made he should still play
1977 7f 4 and maybe
well worse worst case you can still play
Knight f7 here that's true yeah I can
get a pawn easily an i7 king at seven
listen it takes okay what about well
even here right I don't know yeah it's
very difficult it's already really bad
so here it's like I was like Oh mad
sometimes sometimes and you don't get
your night out you just never get it out
right and and this do you think he
missed it or he just I don't think he
missed it but perhaps he didn't see
anything better right yeah I was happy
to fight this combination really nice
yeah right so let's just show everybody
the poor Knight now cannot come out
because of Queen e7 right yeah really
nice and it's kind of like yeah yeah and
if you play something like me five I
would play Queen D fall and then
dramatic 24 work up six maybe even
Queenie six to right okay good
so he sacked the piece but now you're
just you've got too much yeah right well
very nice game very nice game and this
puts you back in the tournament right
yeah okay congratulations thank you
yeah well what can I see more and as I
predicted we're getting a little bit
more fighting chests now can I get your
opinion it seems to me let's get your
opinion on two games so first what do
you is your first take on the ssamjang
black is definitely pushing
this is Sam small prey yeah
lost our just terrible it's terrible but
I think it's horrible okay it's on yep
Oh actually he yeah only one point out
right so if he took on this right now
let's say he takes
he's got a lot of moves like rook da I
think it's lost but okay
he can't move the bishop because of
rookie - oh man oh man yeah
and he did play he played with f d8 rook
e1 one of those moves the energy one
actually a rook H 3 H 8 now I'm sure
Gawain has an idea here but this looked
that looked devastated the good news is
honestly even here you can still click
OK if you want to do right but of course
the rook on h5 is a little bit more
discord and they did right then on h3
right okay and this was an interesting
game where I felt like Daraa was a
little bit better out of the opening but
now maybe worse this whole life both
sides just sit there wait I don't think
they can do much ok I just figured some
it's black who's the one who gets to
decide now whether he plays me five or
c5 something yeah but that's when you
play if I have a few five you open up
space fair enough yet Queen c1 was just
played
good well thank you for coming in yeah
we'll see you soon thank you very much
all right so we got yeah all right so
now we're gonna get a second interview
this is the day of our interviews here
and we're gonna get Egor Kovalenko oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry we will get huger
Kovalenko coming in suit I had assumed
he had one but no it's an it's just a
very nice position and actually let's
just take a brief look at it I assume
we're gonna talk about it when it comes
in very nice actually I'm just gonna
talk about it when he comes in but you
can just get an optical sense here of
whites attack with the rook against the
two pieces and the exposed King he still
has to find several good moves but given
the exposed nature of the King I am
assuming that this has to be winning
even if there are technical difficulties
involved in doing so Ganguly yep Ganguly
is suffering poor guy I thought he
played such a nice such a nice opening
and well now I don't know it's just lost
right yeah is it lost or is it literally
lost it looks like because I literally
lost unfortunate situation we fell apart
what's the last couple rounds he lost or
the last two rounds the Easter of course
started the tournament with two wins and
kind of stagnated from there and I guess
it's it's kind of all come crashing down
for him okay one game we have to talk
about is Oberyn Gregorio Prince game
against Sevilla and you know it's funny
the Oberyn style is let's call it that
let's call it a classic Soviet style and
for that reason what I mean by that is
just trying to get very stable
advantages as white without risking too
much and then as black he is just trying
to equalize so we don't were unfairly
not talking about his games that much
because they're not as exciting as flat
and flashy as the others but what you
can see in this
is somebody who is gonna push for very
small advantages and let's just show a
tactic that could be an a tactic
strainer book here white to play and get
an advantage Bishop takes B staff there
it is very nice and if Knight takes b7
what do we do uh I'm gonna say Queen
takes because he takes me said ah that's
right all right so white got this
advantage it's not over yet black still
has a very powerful Knight and this is
going to lead us into the situation we
have here where I look patiently
creating the passport and the difficulty
and we're gonna see it in this position
here is simply that the knight wants to
come a counter plate in particular wants
to do some nasty business with Knights
e2 and e1 so in this position after King
g8 Oberon said you've got nothing and
I'm gonna play a five just push it what
do you think do you believe in this guy
I imagine he he thought about it that's
what blacks only try this game seems to
have some similarities to a game we
looked at yesterday the game between
Alshon and archers Knight songs right
right you know why it has this past pawn
on the Queen side and a bishop versus a
knight although in that case they're
also just rooks on the board instead of
Queens but then black fellas counter
play and a mating attack against the
White King and it turned out to be
winning for black yeah this one of
course there's no rook fortunately for
white and you know when you imagine this
91 check the worst thing that's gonna
happen is 91 Knight takes f3
it's no there's no further tricky dis
after that and that might well get you a
a drawing position but you're not going
to win it so elbrun has several moves
here to think about here let's see what
he does he goes ahead and plays h4 and
says you have nothing well I enjoyed
coming back for a couple minutes but we
now have another interviewee ready great
sylvanas kibou Z and just won his game
II and sir
Ganguly we were just looking at that and
I believe he's ready to come into the
studio great let's get him in here
and while we're getting him in let's
just look at this age for move and I
think I'm gonna say the idea of
something like this we're gonna give you
this pawn on f3 we're just going to gift
it to you and then we're gonna play a
move either Queen d4 or Queen c5 and say
you have no counter play and that what
is important in chess is pursues not a
chess but in the Queen ending is not the
how many pawns you have but how many
pass pawns and so this is a very simple
and beautiful structure where white will
play Queen b6 a6 a7 and there's no way
to stop that so it seems a technically
in a position very nice play okay we
have Mr GU Busey and in with us yeah
really interesting game this is our
second Sicilian with Knight f3
so we're copying the other game that we
had earlier and here we are any thoughts
on this opening before we get into the
game actually I didn't expect this
language Bishop e3 so I wasn't prepared
I remember at some point she said one
the line that they prepared before the
tournament but I'm sure somewhere I
messed up and I got just a terrible
position right yeah it seemed like he
had the like the dream position yeah it
was a great advantage I was I didn't
know where to put my pieces because it
was like a disaster yeah I'm playing the
neither of like 15 years I never
remember me having such a bad position
out of the opening like so quickly and
you did like all of those moves you just
did seemed pretty normal but already it
seems difficult I have a feeling I
should have played probably not c5 and
try to keep my bishop on e6 because
we're here after Queen e2 I don't know
how to react because Asics is hanging
all the time so I can have to evacuate
so any Knight c5 even I guess he can
take somewhere or it doesn't really have
any ideas so he just plays f3 how
happened in the game later yeah and so I
don't really threaten to play Knight
because b6 is gonna be hanging and it's
not really really clear how to put my
pieces so I just tried to put my rock on
see it and keep it solid but it was
really bad position like pressure was
growing with every movement right yeah
so I'll tell you what this is what I
thought his critical I thought all these
moves he made were brilliant yeah they
were a good move yeah so my point here
was just not to lose immediately you
know when you have such a bad position
okay yeah to try to hold it uh-huh yeah
and I actually I thought my queen on
effect is gonna be worried solid to keep
my king safe I like protection and be
sick so I mean it's textbook what he did
right really nice yeah really this is a
dream position for white and after 95 it
wasn't it did it 22 here here right
there yeah well I thought actually I
thought this was his critic like from
here on I felt like he something slipped
yeah if I don't like really fight yeah
cuz it gives me some options to play
Bishop e6 probably it should be
something with 93 but the problem of
white is whenever I play we should be
six in many positions I'm going to
pretend play c4 and the b2 is hanging
accidentally like my passive rooks on b8
and c6 are starting to play and it's not
very simple how correct maybe a simple
move like we like Queen to the light
scores e to or f1 our stuff and I was
going to play probably be should be six
I don't see any much okay and then and
then maybe because 94 is no longer on
the table maybe f4 well I don't like it
for for white because they're weakening
dark squares and actually I have a dark
Bishop so imagine if I even if I take
and then something like 98 which looks
super passive but I'm gonna activate my
Bishop 45 56 well I will have some rug
before moves and actually at least I got
some counter play don't know how they
but okay but yeah this was the moment
where it's it obviously or at least it
seems obvious the white has an advantage
but it's hard to find it for sure I had
the same feeling that was my kind of
surprised because I don't have the
opening comments prepared to resign
somewhere whenever he makes some tax
yeah grab my pieces so I like okay and
here it wasn't that easy to find
something yeah you know I don't know how
I've been following a Ghoulies games and
it's he's been playing beautiful
positional chess and then last round two
he was doing okay and then you know
faltered in the end and so this was like
a far is the beginning it's not he's
still better is a five square and when
you place a five he's probably gonna
play Bishop a4 so everybody should be
six and this route before movies gonna
count somewhere so sure come here and
this idea route before pawn sacrifice
1964 six before I don't know like the
engine evaluation but during the game I
had the feeling that at least I'm not
bad anymore cuz yeah between and he
activated these two yes suddenly my
setup like super passive setup with
Queen afraid Bishop e7 became really
good enough yeah I think that I think
that was missed I don't know what I
don't know what he should do in this
position I think it's very what's
biggest problem but definitely not
taking it you sure first sure yeah for
sure I don't know much but I didn't see
much opens for him I don't know maybe
the mistake was before cuz she's
publishing floor is fine I was already
going to play for a win here like
because if he plays Knight something
like Knight f5 I just take nine to five
I be sure but five he takes if I can
just take on veto so he'd be sure only
four is a real disaster for white now
and after something gauge Devin's Bishop
before Bishop c5 when it's a little bit
position fork over it so yeah now I I
guess I pray the blunder an idea for and
I don't see because I fight with the
only or logical way to continue
otherwise I take on the 1493 ended yeah
then it's it's like yeah it happened so
fast we would from such a beautiful
position yeah yeah
thank you yeah okay yeah we've seen a
lot of games this tournament where the
defender comes back and wins it's like
from a physician it seems like that
possible
yeah took on this success it coroneted
yeah all right well thank you for coming
in yeah it's very nice let me get your
opinion on what some of these games my
sense okay this one might be easy that
that seems lost for Savion right put the
Queen on b6 and March the pawns oh yeah
this this end games are usually like if
ponies an f2 there there are no real
checks anywhere so he's drugged probably
gonna give some post like g5 I don't
need fifty forty three but it doesn't it
never works right for me to make five so
it's lost for sure I guess so let's look
how about this one oh yeah black might
be winning because of course they're the
opposite colored bishops but roofs are
super active and it's not very simple to
find a place for a king
maybe king gave why should you play it
yeah because King bee won't look super
dangerous but I don't know it looks like
some techniques are gonna come up cuz
this point of c3 is protected and what
can start using the active position of
the ropes maybe some rookie I don't know
this position requires some calculation
right right right yeah my sense was it
for easy but of course great chances to
win I guess right right yeah that was my
sense okay thanks so much for coming in
thank you - all right all right
everybody we will look at some of these
other games as we heard Liam Lee say he
thought this position would David Howell
and Darrow was about equal I I guess I
have an old-school sense that this part
is a target and that we've prevented it
from moving forward to defy
nimzowitsch called this the incinerator
so that's why I feel like if anyone's a
little bit better it's black we're going
to be headed into incredible time
pressure
though in the next couple was and so
mistakes will be made and if we get a
shot of daro I guarantee he is sitting
up on his ankles Jose I guess I got
caught on that one usually when he's in
really deep thought he'll be sitting up
on his ankles like a little kid and it's
kind of fun to watch so he's thinking
here and I really like David house
fighting spirit either both the English
guys they're fighting every time also
playing very creative chest yeah okay
Igor's game arguably Friedman has made
progress in consolidating his King so
maybe that maybe the early call I have
to admit when we were talking before the
round I said well we're gonna get an
early interview with iguanas his winning
and the position he got here he's a
beautiful I thought well really
interesting thing that he did so if we
go back in this position I thought he
was a little bit better and then he made
this weird move before and I didn't
really understand this move a fight
happened and it's like we it seems on
the surface that we really helped black
out because all of a sudden now it looks
like there's this play and maybe the
Queen will go back to eight eight to
protect this Bishop this was blacks only
real problem watch what he does this is
very reminiscent of a lot of the
Kasparov games from the 1980s we're
gonna play d5 opening the bishop cutting
the Queen right edie and we're gonna say
Queen you need to go somewhere else
hmm he takes know that was a big
decision and maybe Queen a6 was better
but here we go
snip get to the misérable King there's
that famous Kasparov rule of like
cutting the board into fourths and
seeing where the pieces are and so all
the flex pieces especially the Queen is
kind of stuck on the Queen side right
that's why you can start doing this this
type of sacrifice
and one actually one reason that I
thought I still think this was totally
winning for white this particular
position I don't know about later is
there's a game with Kasparov against
Porter's 1983 very similar same piece
dynamic with two ropes a minor against
the three minors and because the king is
open you can say it's over and I think
that's true but somehow Igor lets this
thing go wow it still seems it still
seems great it's hard to imagine it's
hard to imagine here and actually with
with the Kasparov game was the D file
and here it's the e file that's cutting
the trying at least to cut the board in
two and I don't know if we technically
cut it that's gonna be an interesting
question
Bishop f7 both sides are still gonna
make numerous mistakes here because of
the time pressure of course a lot harder
for white to play so my brute force way
to try to play it would just be h5 and
h6 sure looks like h5 s actually is age
five yeah then played although I wait
Stern again I can't see really yeah they
got the Sun yeah another board we can't
really tell but h5 definitely on the
board first day not full of rain in st.
Louis oh and then Rick d5 was play d5
okay here we see both players down to
about five minutes on the clock so
obviously trying to make it a little
difficult maybe with an idea like h6 9
g6 but white can do a lot of different
things yeah this should be winning a lot
of options there's this is this is of
course you can blow it but white should
be winning yeah I really like this game
and I I did I'm gonna ask him but it'll
be interested in that when he played
before what I want to know was he
tempting black to bring the Queen off of
the defense of the King that's the thing
I want to know because when you look at
this position I feel like whites a
little bit better hmm because of the the
awkward nature of the knight on c6 but
it's hard to know what to do and before
oh yeah doesn't it seem like we're
actually threatening anything and it
invites a 5:1 weird thing about it is
it's black could have played just Knight
takes and I assume he's okay yeah I
think it's pretty deep to say before I
was trying to lure the Queen away away
from the Kings side but but maybe I mean
what is true is that that if you want a
mate black you need to get the Queen out
of there mmm and so yeah oh yeah we
interesting to ask what motivations b4
b4 worth if they were to bring the Queen
over I think that would be kind of
amazing if it was okay as we said before
it looks like Sam is losing against over
very nice technical play here and yeah I
think this is just over in a very
classic way so why don't we check in on
Dmitry Gordievsky against Brandon Jacobs
says sure like quite a bit has changed
since the last lick to back in oh man
well the suffering is similar yeah it's
anything it's similar
well let's still suffering but maybe in
let's let's look what we weren't around
this position right alright let's see
what happened h6 Bishop f4 they should
be set
simple chess efore
now maybe this is unhappy to play Queen
a1 just because with that extra the
extra plan I feel is best served as as
an attacker mm-hmm but okay so here we
go snip snip
rook a8 would be one and maybe white
missed that even if he did he still
arguably has a very nice advantage and
there's a simple question right about
does g4 win the game well at first
glance I want to say yes so rook b8
mm-hmm no I know I just moved over I
just moved the bishop so what is g4
might simply end it yeah I'm I'm sure
looking to find find a reason reason why
it wouldn't well let's do actually have
moves being played here it looks like
rook c1 was played attacking the bishop
but still this g4 move is going to be an
option right so c1 in Bishop a4 and
let's put g4 back and see if we're
missing something here hmm
just looks like a piece to me
it also gives our King a square to move
to yeah
making moved in the best possible way
and the nice thing of course is that
it's really nice at this Knights protect
they don't have to worry about all kinds
of other stuff right
Gordievsky has seconds but he's figuring
it out he's wondering about June 12 but
he he's worried about something on g4 no
know what it is yet so just place your
k1 I don't I don't understand what the
concerns were but does this give black a
chance to play something like g5 now to
try and try and evacuate before it's too
late
yeah and the good news well no because
Bishop b5 there should be five okay so
of course Lim Bishop c2 this Bishop c6
to break the pin but yeah so Rick a1 is
making a threat so arguably the g4
hasn't gone anymore and and I don't know
what the concern was maybe it was some
kind of Bishop a3 thing buddy case here
we have Bishop b4 it's an interesting
way to try and and now were touching the
balance this guy which might help us if
any kind of rip d8 business so is that
the plan on Bishop d5 know to play rip
d8 well let's let's let's imagine g4
rook d8
it looks like the plan he does play g4
oh no he doesn't
that was me that was you BG for his
plate actually okay say G for him okay
good
and maybe he might have given him a shot
out of this game how did this let's see
I didn't think it was working so rook da
yeah rook to e8
what if I just take on eight four okay
good
so d2 mm-hmm and then you can solve on
82 and then I'll just put the bishop
back on 83 good good good the knight
maintains the the mites the Knights
still lacks it's squares and I think
we're seeing something very similar to
that right now
yep because the board is resolved in
play Oh Brandon you were doing so well
buddy doing so well Rick t3 we're suing
Bishop e3 Oh Brandon buddies I guess
it's resigned I can't even give up the
exchange anyway cuz if rook takes the
three pawn takes c3 in the night it's
still trapped so I made final gordy ask
you for traded Queens but that worked
out very quickly right away yeah this
guy knew what he was doing
let's actually look at how clever that
was so Ruby ate Queen a1 now they're in
time pressure so all kinds of things are
happening but of course here here
of course the claim is that the bishop
is bad okay 8'o right so the rook e8
arguably now what you need is Bishop a8
mm-hmm Bishop a8 - there's you got at
least wonder about rook a 7 yeah
everything all the pieces they are just
a little awkward yeah yeah so actually
this Queen a1 move was and so I'm sorry
if you play Bishop a is there just a 97
so I'm gonna say maybe you should have
done Bishop b7 here okay so what were
you saying so you were saying Bishop a8
insider' okay it may be yeah and then
rook a 787 evening
that's what made me nice I can both are
the same because I'm 95 we've got de
sure so this looks like it's forcing we
do see a handshake there so resignations
over the board and and so probably in
these early positions g4 would have won
as well but white is just making sure
making fairly easy making sure it work
so very nice game from Dmitry and Dmitry
can you tell me what's what's his score
now I pledge to write its + - yeah let's
- a half point behind our turrets who is
+3 on the event so far and made a quick
draw today maybe he's feeling a little
too secure we might not be enough with
Dimitri hot on his tail so what is going
on in Group A all right let's check back
in on those games with with the
suffering that we like to talk about so
here we go with Sam mm-hmm really a lot
of ways the game of the day here so I
feel like maybe Dwyane gave stranglin a
little bit more play than he wanted but
at the same time the suffering is so
long-term so are you prepared for a
third interview should we try to get
Gordievsky down here before our clock
runs out we can and you know it's funny
I've been pining for an interview with
Kovalenko and the guy hasn't been able
to finish off Friedman if Gordievsky
wants to grace us with his presence
again I'd be happy to have it let's put
it that way
rook h7n actually maybe this is
something I don't understand here
because I would expect Bishop g7 my that
would all says man maybe we were missing
something them because that's so obvious
with Bishop g7 well it's the party
which porn thing see three maybe I
simple enough very good that's right
okay yes so rip g7 and this is gonna
help white defend this trade and that's
exactly what happens with so Brooke age
seven I'm gonna guess that was something
that going overlooked because in general
we don't want to trade off the rooks
when I have the initiative this is now
with one rook I'm gonna change my
opinion now with the one rook is it this
is arguably well at least a lot easier
now Brooke a7 which I feel like a rookie
should have come to a seven a long time
ago but Brooke a 7v7 one of those moves
still looks like it creates drama for
black
I believe we actually have Dimitri ready
to come in for you right so I will once
again step out of my chair and we'll get
him here in the studio and while we're
doing that let's look at Howells game
against daro and I was partial to
Howells position precisely because he
could make a break like 85 whereas white
had to wait and so here we go
'if I've aged five may be controversial
snip snip snip
and then the night lands okay very nice
play and if I understand it we are
making claims about how we are gonna
simply win this guy and then our night
is going to be better than this bishop
that's blocked in and maybe we're gonna
regret this h5 move as well so we'll
keep an eye on that that's big-time
pressure that's huge time pressure
happening there a lot of games in time
pressure so I have mister Gordievsky
here he came in yesterday won again and
so we're gonna talk to him again here
and let's pull this game up
so Demetri congratulations you got angry
you got angry an hour I fire no I don't
know how to explain it so bad
what was the funny thing I'm gonna I'm
gonna guess you were unprepared for that
move DC general speaking I I mean he
played is six two times so three g6
Kings Indian stuff and some beautiful
different and I didn't expect that and I
thought for some reason that he didn't
analyzed Bishop g5 yeah I don't know why
because I also didn't analyze Bishop g5
right I mean I thought that okay we will
get some game transposition to Queens
gambit declined after we should be 793
mm-hmm or maybe 693 I remember a few
games
my MIDI are played this I think
something like this h6 Bishop h4 but in
his games one was on g5 and there was
compensation but here after d5 take c4 I
even I don't know what - well I think
you got Knight c3 is your first
candidate right nice a three a six I
think that it is the reason why white
don't play Bishop g5 because for example
after Knight c3 c5 take the c4 here if
or is the clearly main move right
why don't play Bishop g5 I think because
the phase 6 and here is this is
transposition is not it's not very good
for white I think so that's the question
okay you played let's just say this is
the cautious move III yeah but I mean
after Queen a4 check this is all lazy
move yeah you should do a lazy I mean
probably objectively best you should do
lazy move right but okay who knows I
mean Bishop g5 cannot be just so bad
move that white is worse and forced to
play III but you know what let's just I
think let's well we're gonna talk about
so you felt already that I felt you were
still
I didn't think like anything had gone
there no I mean it should be cool but
what I did
yes clearly worse right right right okay
well let's get into it yeah this
position is critical maybe here I had to
play something like a ting not a it'd
take me five maybe be three here more I
think if I first mission before any King
give one you know what I still thought
you were okay here though yeah but like
even what's my plan I could not
understand how to develop pieces because
for example instead of Queen take b3
something like dream scenario for me was
92
instead of Quinte b3 but I didn't see
what to do against before but like let's
say this position instead of rook e1
what about like us just a simplistic
move like either here 92 or c3 one of
those I don't know maybe d2 yes but you
should be seven and I think some day I
just was some day 95 some day my night
for example on d5 square okay I'll just
play a couple of C okay Castle I'm not
sure that's
yeah but what if I just take and play 97
there just resign or not I don't like
resigning something like it looks so bad
something like this you know I don't
know and you were gonna try to put the
night here
yeah but even even maybe I can even do
that I don't know 94 immediately yeah
Bishop takes you five take Missy eight
Queen take a five I think that I have
too many pawns no how about a four oh
yeah that's that's that's drunk all I
know all I I mean I don't really know
anything but I just feel like you still
have in this position you still have
enough you know you might it might be
hard to find the plan that you you still
have to have enough in these position
during the game it should prove that
yeah yeah yeah okay um it was too
difficult tell me if you think the
following so I thought this was like his
critical position yes of course it's
like I offer to drop him to him right
here and I think he was thinking about
one hour huh
the grace I mean I just could not
understand what to do I went to wait in
the room I do some food so do you think
he missed or underestimated 95 at the
end of all this so went c5 like here is
their thing he can do so many different
things here right no I mean if he just
stays it's very comfortable because I
moved my knight - very good square on g3
I play Bishop III and I started to like
my position it like done 25 maybe the
next move would be broken b1 because I
mean if black don't play c5 I can
prepare for this move better and take on
b5 and I never would be worse
I mean I'm not going to say that white
is wet or something like that but for
example my next move would be an ID for
and then I just take one f6 so maybe h6
for example yes h6 Misha page four but
here maybe should I
I understood that instead of 92 I was
thinking about Bishop h4 because after
all this c5 exchanges queen and c5
attack my bishop on g5 but here
I mean h6 Bishop h4 is good for me I
think okay nice now he has this option
anyways here we go c5 a of course the
strongest was c5 take before there is no
God
so that's like I thought that I can hold
this but it would be very long suffer I
mean we take a six
Bishop take a six night take quintic be
696 we take before and this is slightly
pours forward yeah yeah but I thought
that I couldn't I mean I didn't have any
better opportunity okay fair enough
so here Knight f3 Bishop of one in this
position it looks bad but yeah okay you
have chances to hold this thing sure
yeah I mean 70% for holding 34 losing I
think so like I always loved when the
statisticians come out alright so this
was okay what did he miss I guess that's
what marketers know because he was
thinking for so long and I mean after 95
black almost losing in yeah I mean not
losing it would be not so easy it had to
be not so easy to convert from him he
had underestimated this move even though
it looks simple it's like no I don't
know what he thought that I'm just going
to resign after something like I don't
know I just didn't have any options
instead of 95 right right yeah you're
forced to do with you
maybe he calculated sound like night I
for
before and then II for once okay so this
position that we get would did you feel
this was winning for you or just better
I mean it's just we need just winning
right yes but in the game you know you
should play this slowly and I wanted to
find something force and take wouldn't
why would you say it's winning okay
the best way for me for example it's
exchange old pieces and leave my night
against black Bishop okay yeah yes
because our end game would be winning
night against night without heavy pieces
because to be nian what it's not so easy
to get this position because I thought
that after age six I could play
something like 95 Queen moves take on
the seventh take we should take the
eighth hope take the 8 and here actually
it is not so easy okay
I thought it was funny because my
intuition was a little bit different I
felt like it was winning because the
extra pawn should mean that you can
create an attack later on you know but
your I your method was better where you
know took away all the squares method
would yeah to wait for blunder because I
wanted to keep my pieces and actually
it's not so easy to play for black also
maybe Queen a7 here right Queen a 787
instead of a just because when you when
heat when this happens Queen 84 his
Bishop is kind of is got problems right
yes here here force first play comes
like I was already having trouble I
guess a little bit is just terrible move
no no no right right right I mean my
plan was let's say B should be seven
right yeah to grab for a and B line for
example Queen a1 and room B 1 in some
moment but here I wanted to play 95 c 4
after a B so bizarre and I still have a
lot of pieces and next move is
sounds like a jelly to protect my bishop
after it after I will put on III sure
you give to f3 to again f3 I don't want
one of those moves yeah yeah ok
and then Queen a one room B 1 and
because of swearin wait right it's under
my bishop sure sure yeah let's show that
so that just a simple idea to say that
you're gonna win the B file
yes okay that's nice yeah and the pawns
are dominating the black miners right
let me ask you a question so what this
all happened and of course time pressure
was happening and it wasn't and Brooke
c1 I could not understand which move is
Binion immediately this one just feels
well I guess they're both great yeah
they're both good yeah because after
Roxy won the only line which black have
is Bishop e7 night take d7 take rooks e7
guru K 1 is mistake because of native
one and I mean it's immediately Bishop
c8 this should be 5
here miss of g8 group the xe8 rock tied
c8 miss peg the sound
Brooksie one night f1 and Ruby one in
the end black boy Bishop e6 and then I
didn't see the way to protect my phone I
mean I can play sound like like g500
you should pay for maybe d5 TV no d5
with the way just to get three against
three
but this one we keep the big holder
right yes yeah I didn't see before
yeah your way was fine but anyway I'd be
so pay for who could be one from before
idea I mean if I lose d4 pawn it should
be huge chances to win huh however I
wasn't sure I mean when you have this
position you don't generally want well
okay so here's our question
we were wondering here you had okay you
could have played g4 in this move and
then also lets you had a couple chances
play g4 before you did it yes okay I
mean I'm not sure that it's not it's so
easy
I mean after Bishop e2 okay one is on
the spot but here after j4 Rudi it is
possible and what to do I'm not sure
that it's so easy win the Bishop g5 is
next move and a grab a Foursquare or
night on g2 will be unprotected so it's
very taking oh good rugby three [ __ ]
people
rook p3 Misha people pay for and is it
is even you know for example okay
example I could I mean I had one minute
I tried to put a sound like Ruby 7 right
because now Rudy 3 is impossible as a
group take me seven but here a
missionary five basic g5 so same idea
yeah
okay good that's good to know so very
precise rook c1 yeah we should a for and
is g4 possible here
yeah but the idea if black plays Bishop
yet instead would be should pay for
because we shall pay for looks very
dangerous I mean to put pieces under the
spin but Bishop e8g for here I think it
here is possible because I have Ruby
eight rooks III and we should be for OB
3i I have been three very nice very nice
yeah and it should be winning people the
same stuff would be worse
and that's it and so yes so he played
Bishop a4 here I again cannot play g4
because of the same reason prove date
very nice Brooks III and we should
before so I played through k1 instead
and here the only move was Bishop g5
otherwise if you just resigned on the
spot so I I didn't have time and I
wasn't sure that I cannot that I that I
can't find the best way here so it's
very tricky because after Bishop e5 you
always have fruit date but you know you
could let's say Bishop b5 through the
88's I take it that way take on it read
yeah and I still have yes yes that's
that's a good way i I hope with the
Irish pawn structure yes
yeah I hope that I could find that but
I'm not sure I mean I've had about one
minute or one minute yeah no you played
without really well we we were kind of
looking at other games and looking at
the same time but we missed a lot of
that Stan you found instantly
okay well that plus two coming into it
congratulations let's get your opinion
on something we've asked it everyone's
opinion on this on this game over here
with Sam it's obviously evolving
mistakes being made probably on both
sides yeah what wasn't the result oh you
mean this game this game yeah now it
looks drost I'm gonna say but I guess
yeah what do you think I can give up my
you give it well yeah so sad for Gawain
he was I thought we were back here yeah
just go here for sure I thought this was
winning actually this position we
thought rook e8 instead of rook ft and
we're like what look at that thing
you know maybe usurpation 7 check
yes it's hard to imagine it's hard to
imagine I mean
I mean when you sit over the board
usually very scary no I'm sure that's
something like that yes I mean you sound
like Rudy too can get 3c2 and someone
give might I'm in there after oops if I
threw k3 but you never know during the
game right because one not precise move
and you lose immediately or even vanish
that's right yes but it sound like what
he did
oh I mean now we're just like like that
yeah okay let me ask you let me get your
opinion another one too
what this one yeah well which game were
you interested in uh pardon that was
just a loss yeah that's so he won
I actually the the move stopped coming
through but he won yeah I mean I stopped
you he's good when he was pulling up I
think yeah he was upon oh yeah
unfortunately I don't know my my peach
him it's gone missing we came though for
endgame
I know I mean I'm sure he won but yeah
yeah yeah yeah well really game did you
want Austin this one with the Hal game
oh man what a mess for a while there I
thought that howl was better obviously
we had some time scramble and now I
don't know what's happening
it wasn't with her I thought he was
better yeah
so we should have electoral but now I
guess our basic problem is if there
should be five we've got to check check
on the Queen eight - yeah so but here
were five you have to calculate vamoose
but then we finally in the end of this
line after Queen take a five because it
seems like it should be five who is the
only move
I don't believe that it's possible to in
this position take on a four
I mean I can just move my pawn c5
suppose you know
sequel
let's get four queens 3a6
Quincy seven oh man away yeah I have no
idea
no it's just impossible to me in such
positions so let's go back to this Queen
because well let's say this so we're in
this position now and White's thinking
about it and if black doesn't take on e5
it seems like he's gonna be worse seems
like freak one right yeah so knowing g4
next ten Queen d7 just resigned I mean
yeah so you gotta do this thing so you
have to 28th d5 because it seems like it
was
g4 is always impossible maybe I could
get I know you should be five used only
more for the rice and black or just
starting a talking well I can also play
Queen d2 it's similar to what we just
it's similar oh yes okay so yeah I guess
that's looking like it's headed towards
the draw yeah then let's see if oh you
know this was a funny game
I think this Kovalenko game I thought
for sure yes yes yes this is abuse your
pages save on I thought for sure he was
gonna win like an hour ago you know I
know we're dealing with this later
Levine in position you thought so too
right it looked like clearly winning
yeah and now maybe it's it's still
better maybe it was time trouble for him
I'm not sure yeah well what what is this
well if we change Queens it should be
winning providing mm-hmm really winning
three Queens yeah I mean coupons always
win again to pieces we only have one
pawn I mean the three gets one yeah I
mean connected pawns and I think here or
c4 c5 pawn doesn't make any sense
because I just put my rook but on the
other hands if you don't exchange the
Queens
then you know if long-term the black
king should be worse right black ink
right
well always when you move your pawn on
Japan there's a five square for tonight
and who's King who would be in danger so
for example if the purpose here to
change Queens what would it be the move
so it it black to move right it's back
to move and for example this Queen
question comes up right away because one
move he could play is night at five and
then you have to worry about looks like
I mean they just queenie five friend is
it free piece no it might be a free
piece that's because that I have night
h4 what a tricky well I mean when you're
in this position you need to fix your
Knights right you're gonna try to do
something like that night on h4 this so
bad because I can play even just if -
and why you put your night on h4 square
well I'll go check to the misérable key
quickly just few checks
Oh
and that's in squared it's very rookie
to Quincy Wow
yeah I mean if I through its beautiful
move anyways that's what he's got it's
something like that is what he's
thinking of right now I mean why should
I
but otherwise maybe if you think that
your position is just very bad yeah you
are looking for chances I mean that's
the first move came to my mind I want to
get out of there I don't like that light
city but yeah night v Queen Bey check
I have also there's a lot of things it's
nothing nothing crazy like king gage
seven and windy one yeah I don't know
what is that but if i g 6g 6
yeah I mean he created a lot of problems
let's say let's say though in this
position of like if you're black your
intuition is what what is it yeah it's
what he took on h5 I mean did we'd not
even see that did we miss this maybe no
it it is drawn up immediately
I mean after okie five Quincy one rookie
one queen g5 it doesn't change anything
it seems like as it just they're off
there is clearly no way Hawaii and I
think he just misses what was work his
previous no prominent say he had such a
nice position it's such a beauty for
three yeah but every since like the only
no father would he talk before so the
mistake wasn't made previously I mean
we'll go back to this position look at
this position he had i what i was like
that's a brilliancy i want to talk to
this guy I want to bring him into the
studio you know the whole thing and how
much time did he had more time at this
point yeah okay let me get your opinion
because I'm not gonna be able to get him
in here so I just want to ask your
opinion in this position no I was trying
to find a clear in oh yeah I'm sure
there's a clear with yeah but we're
looking at this position I was saying to
myself you know this move did white
black white play this move as a trick
because it seems to invite a five and
Queen takes it seems to invite it and
then once it's invited right then we've
blocked the Queen out and then we get
that business and boom yes if it works
and just amazing yeah it's a beautiful
move yeah so what do I mean
why like way to Pooky Pooky for well I
think it was our do I think that was
forced how white teenage 899 95 right
yes and no defense and after King and
what if Kim ug8 instead of same thing
same thing
ng v g6 me just six yeah
all right the end beautiful
yeah really nice and the thing I want to
have wonder though right is like did
he'd know it did he see kind of the idea
when he did this
that would be next level if you saw the
idea already with before no maybe when
you're white you just think that okay
I'm not going to play g5 it just will be
always draw what's my move instead of
before I have something like h3 so
what's my idea maybe I can put my rook
on c-file rookie - Luke see - but all of
this doesn't look scary for black so you
think okay I play before it does not let
move maybe some class somewhere I will
play Quincy 3 and B 5 and then black
answered a 5 here L has they'd be take a
5 only move I mean we take a 5 for I
think was possible but he played queen
85 and you think okay so and then maybe
he found this idea I think it was like
the right okay well the guys are telling
me it's we're past the hour so you're at
plus 2 now right yeah
very good yeah of course you can win the
whole thing yeah so congratulations so
hopefully see you back here again and
are we gonna do a wrap-up yeah I will do
a wrap-up here thing all right thank you
so much all right while we're getting
Caleb in here let's just say poor poor
Gawain that's his position he's gonna
make it maybe to a hundred moves in his
frustration and David Howell is trying
to imagine if he can get away with
Bishop b5 we think you can then of
course Igor is still fighting it looks
like it's gonna be a draw a remarkable
save in that game Oberon one of course
and L Sean Drew
with the count we didn't talk about that
game but I'll Sandra with the count and
our tours of course that early draw with
the Cobian and Brandon Jacobson lost a
Gordievsky as we just witnessed really
crushing blow we needed people to let
him win so they needed to keep playing
chess and being encouraged because it's
very hard to be a young man and also be
a genius and what it does have
encouraged me yeah what a day and what a
tournament so far why don't we take a
look and see where all those crazy
results left us after the the action of
today so Lee Anne Lee of course won his
game putting him at +1 on the tournament
against Geoffrey Zhang David Howell is
still playing but it looks like the rest
of the games in Group A are gonna shake
out to be a draw this is what we're
expecting so at the end of today
hopefully we will have Liam Lee its Hyde
with David hell up at the top with
Jeffrey Sam and going all following
close behind at an even score and over
in Group E Thank You Rory Oberon
continues his streak and wins his game
today I'm putting them at five points a
full point of head of the next closest
Havana's Qaboos Ian who won his game
against Sergio Ganguly continuing kind
of gang Ghoulies downfall in this event
after that beautiful start with two wins
to start the tournament now two losses
in the last two rounds
Sam Savino is also following but lost
his game as well at three and a half
points
Daniel Friedman and Igor Kovalenko are
still going but now you know this is the
game we were just looking at we're
expecting maybe a draw
Igor definitely let something slip there
and in Group C returns Mike Sun is still
the tournament's sole leader with the
draw today putting them at Five Points
but Dimitri Gordievsky continues to win
and it is hot on his trail Alshon of
course drew his game as you just
mentioned against the count and her own
poco bein also drew today against
archers and Brandon Jacobson after that
wonderful start leading the tournament
we thought he was back on track
yesterday but the loss today definitely
has to hurt a little bit yeah we
have some exciting upcoming broadcasts
after this tournament as well as during
this tournament there's some exciting
stuff going on the Croatia leg of the
grand chest or a classical chest leg
actually is going to be starting
tomorrow so tomorrow morning be sure to
join us here and you can watch the grand
chess to our coverage live our show is
actually problem might be impacted a
little bit by this show we will be
starting either at 3:30 or if Croatia
runs a bit long we'll be starting a half
hour after the end of the Croatia
broadcast in Africa Asia we actually
have more chess action here in the st.
Louis the u.s. Junior Championship the
u.s. girls junior championship and the
u.s. Senior Championship are all coming
to st. Louis starting July 10th so we
will have a coverage over all of that
here as well well what do you think
about the games today beautiful games
beautiful games it's getting really
intense yeah and it's gonna continue for
the next we got three more rounds yeah
three more rounds around eight nine and
ten around longer than last year I
believe yeah so my name is caleb Envy
this is Jim Jesse cry it's been a
pleasure hosting you here for that today
for round seven and hopefully you guys
can join us tomorrow for more action at
the summer chess classic this has been a
presentation of the st. Louis chess club
[Music]
you
you